the first democratic debate was anything
but boring the American people are sick
and tired of hearing about your Damn
emails unless somebody mentions my name
I can't get in to discuss are you saying
you didn't know what you were voting for
I think you're being a little rough I
just arrived at the United States Senate
with the topic that really got
candidates heated gun control this has
gone on too long and it's time the
entire country stood up against the NRA
we did it over on you by leading with
principal not by pandering to the NRA
well as an audacity in our voting record
and I have an S I don't think I am
handling but you have not been in the
United States Congress but while the
candidates had a lot to say what are
their past policies tell us about how
they might deal with gun violence as
president well for one senator Bernie
Sanders who got a lot of heat at the
debate has a pretty checkered past on
gun control in 1993 he voted against a
five-day waiting period for buying guns
at the time he said he was holding up
his promise to his constituents in
Vermont a big hunting state then in 2005
Sanders voted for a bill that shielded
gun manufacturers from lawsuits it was
an NRA back to Phil Sanders has said he
would support gun control as president
but he hasn't unveiled a plan yet
meanwhile Hilary Clinton managed to
appear more progressive than Sanders on
the issue he was going to give immunity
to the only industry in America
everybody else has to be accountable but
not the gun manufacturers and we need to
stand up and say enough of that after
the recent Oregon shooting Clinton
unveiled a plan that would include
stricter background checks closing
loopholes in the law and preventing
domestic abusers from owning guns how
many people have to die before we
actually act Clinton also said she would
issue executive orders if Congress
wouldn't work with her and her past well
while in the Senate she voted against
that same NRA backed bill that Sanders
supporting but in 2007 while running for
president she softened her rhetoric
calling guns part of our culture and a
way of life in America and the other
three Democratic candidates well lincoln
Chafee a form
senator and governor like Clinton voted
against the NRA backed bill while in the
setting and at the debate Chafee
emphasized the need for an inclusive
approach to gun control I would bring
the gun lobby in and say we've got to
change this where can we find common
ground both he and Martin O'Malley were
governor's when the 2012 Sandy Hook
shootings happened and goes pushed for
strict gun control packages in their
states in 2013 O'Malley signed what was
thought to be the most progressive state
gun law in the country look it's fine to
talk about all of these things and I'm
glad we were talking about these things
but I've actually done them he was also
the first Democratic candidate to
release his gun plan after this month's
Oregon shooting saying his plan would
cut gun violence in half in the next ten
years meanwhile former senator and
Secretary of the Navy Jim Webb is the
biggest gun rights supporter amongst the
Democratic candidates in the debate he
even said but we have to respect the
tradition in this country of people who
want to defend themselves and their
family from violence so in a country
where the NRA still has its grip on
Congress and the Second Amendment
reigned supreme which candidate has what
it takes to win over all of America